"We're like family."
This is a phrase that's become
quite popular in our places of work
to try to make work
feel a little less like this
and a little bit more like this.
It's a phrase that started
in the last decade or two
to try to elicit feelings
of warmth and belonging
and really that "cool culture" vibe.
The laid-back break rooms
with beanbag chairs and the beer on tap
and those tight-knit teams
that got through everything together
like a family.
It's a phrase that started
with positive intent
and has had positive outcome.
However, what's gone far less
recognized and discussed
is how calling work our family
can actually be quite detrimental
to our mental and emotional health
without our knowing it.
Which is why I'm here today to offer
the reminder that work is not your family.
And to explore how this "cool culture"
catchphrase often ends up
breeding burnout instead.
My name is Gloria Chan Packer.
I am a mental wellness educator
and an experienced corporate leader.
In 2018, I founded a company
called "Recalibrate"
to try to deliver workplace
mental wellness services
that were more modern,
accessible and science-backed.
Since that time,
I and my team have gotten to work
with almost 20,000 employees
all over the world.
Now, the reason this topic,
exploring how calling work our family
can be problematic and breed burnout,
the reason it's important to me
is because I've personally lived it.
Before we get into that, though,
let's first baseline by understanding
why calling work our family
at its core can be problematic.
Doing so, psychologically infers
a really big blur
and betrayal in our boundaries.
Work and family are different entities
with different goals,
expectations and responsibilities,
and therefore should be
separated and boundaried.
For example, I'm not going to be
in the shower one day
and notice a really weird mole
on my pregnant belly
and roll into my boss's office
like I would my mom and be like,
"Hey, can you can you get in here
and look at this?
This looks kind of weird.
I'm freaked out."
A few of us are giggling or laughing,
but I'm sure a few of us, too,
in our heads are like,
"Oh, have I done something
weird like that at work?
Have I crossed a boundary before?”
Boundaries are hard for a lot of us
because many of us never
learned boundaries.
It's kind of a newer, buzzy phrase
that not many of us really
have learned or defined before.
So let's start by defining
what boundaries are
and why they're so important
to our mental health.
I like to think of boundaries
as our ability to identify,
communicate and take action on our needs.
Being able to say, "I need to eat,"
"I need to rest,"
"I need some space right now."
Survival speaking, boundaries are critical
for us as humans to be able to say,
"I need something," to be able
to find safety and resourcing.
However, it can also be advantageous
in certain situations
to delay or deprioritize our needs too.
For example,
if I'm a human back in the day,
running away from a tiger,
if I happen to be hungry,
it will, of course, be beneficial
to delay that need for hunger
until I'm safe again.
However, if, after the tiger
has left and I'm safe,
I keep staying stuck
and being scared of the tiger
and delaying my hunger and not eating,
that becomes unhealthy too.
This shift of delaying our needs
into the unhealthy without knowing it
is where a lot of us find ourselves
unknowingly stuck today.
Somewhere in our lives
we learned and adapted
that repressing or sacrificing our needs
for others was beneficial.
But that became so auto-piloted
in our subconscious
that it goes past the point
of diminishing returns
and becomes unhealthy.
To where maybe we land into a workplace
and we hear "we're like family"
and our brain just triggers into
"give it everything no matter what."
We sacrifice our boundaries,
our time, our relationships,
and we start living life in these big
swings of overworking to burnout.
And maybe we rationally know that it's not
the healthiest pattern in our life,
but we feel stuck.
I get that.
I've lived through that and sometimes
still feel challenged with it.
You see, before I worked
in mental wellness,
you could argue that I worked
in the opposite of mental wellness.
I started my career in management
and technology consulting,
spending almost a decade giving it my all.
I did the 80 to 100 hour billing weeks,
the 100-plus fights a year,
for years on end,
the early promotion chase
and didn't scale back
on other parts of my life either.
Still volunteered,
went to my SoulCycle classes
did brunch and late nights with my friends
until my completely overscoped life
turned into burnout cycle
after burnout cycle.
In 2017, my brain and body hit a wall.
I started struggling
with debilitating, chronic migraines
that, for me,
meant that after months of no change
and no medication or treatment working,
I knew I had to take
at least a leave from work.
And that was devastating for me
because work had really
become my everything.
There is a memory
that haunts me from that time.
And it was the night
before I was about to go on leave,
and I was just grabbing dinner
with a friend and my husband.
And I said to my friend,
"Work is my entire worth and my identity.
I don't know what I'm going
to do without it."
And my husband's body language
and face dropped
in a way that I had never seen it.
And after my friend left,
I remember him saying to me,
"I can't believe that you think
that work is your only worth
when I see so much more.
And I can't believe
you can't see that either."
It's a poignant memory for me
because I remember it feeling so true.
And now I know it's not.
But it was a really rough period.
It's such an important one in my life
because it gave me the opportunity
to do my own mental health work
and understand where these burnout
behaviors had come from for me,
so that now I could grow
into being able to discern
when those behaviors
are healthy or unhealthy.
For me, where those behaviors
started and were adopted
is that I grew up learning
that I needed to be perfect
and to people please
and be the best at everything
so that I could get myself
out of a situation
that I felt like I otherwise
wouldn't be able to make it through.
For me,
that perfectionism and people-pleasing
was so critical to that point in my life.
But then when I just put it on autopilot,
it went way past the point
of diminishing returns
and often became unhealthy for me.
That's my story.
Let's spend some time
getting to know yours.
I'm going to invite you to do a little bit
of reflection activity with me
as you're comfortable,
if you can all just close your eyes
wherever you are.
And with your eyes closed,
I'm going to ask you to start
to bring to mind a part of you
that tends to overwork,
to be a perfectionist or a people-pleaser,
struggles to set boundaries.
When I ask what it would be like
if you tone that part of you
back a little.
Just let that go a little.
For the piece of you that pops up
with some tension or resistance,
let's lean into that and ask, why not?
What would happen? What would go wrong?
Would things go wrong,
the other shoe would finally drop,
and it'd be all your fault?
Would you lose success?
Would you not have anything to talk about
in conversation to feel worthy anymore?
Then let's practice some curiosity
around where you might have first
adapted or learned this.
When it might have helped
or protected you in life.
Did you learn early on
you had to be perfect
to avoid shame or discipline?
Or when you were young,
did you learn you had to be
overly self-reliant,
you had to take care
of everything and everyone
because your caretaker couldn't.
Or maybe later in life,
in college,
did you learn it was worth sacrificing
whatever you needed
to get that win or accolade,
maybe to make up for not feeling
accepted earlier in life?
See what it would be to speak
to that part of yourself and say,
"Thank you so much
for making this adaptation.
You helped me through
such an important time,
but right now, I don't need you
to be on the clock all the time anymore.
I have a beautiful life that I've built
with safety and stability,
and I have people in my life
that love me for who I am
and not what I do.
You can take a breather so I can too.”
As you're ready,
just gently opening your eyes back up
and coming back into the room with me.
Welcome back.
So part of that reflection activity
is an example of what
we would technically call
identifying our cognitive schemas.
Our cognitive schemas are essentially
how our brain forms
all of our subconscious behaviors,
patterns, thoughts and emotions
which our brain largely learns
based on past experiences we've had.
A majority of our subconscious schemas,
our behaviors, are formed
and adapted early on in life,
especially in childhood,
because our brains
are kind of blank slates.
We haven't experienced much of life yet,
so out of safety and efficiency,
our brain takes each big
experience and wants to say,
OK, this is what I did,
these were the factors around,
this is what happened
and therefore is how I should predict,
I should feel, think
and act from here on out."
And it puts that on autopilot
into our subconscious.
This can be very beneficial,
and it does keep us safe and efficient.
However, it can also become very outdated
and unhealthy for us too,
which is why it's so important
to do this work.
Now, doing such work is not about saying,
because a lot of our subconscious
behaviors were formed in the past,
that they're all invalid or wrong.
What it is about doing is making sure
we each do our own due diligence
to understand where the blueprint
of our behaviors came from
and ensure they're still relevant
and productive to our current lives.
We update everything else
important in our lives,
from our homes to our technology
to our education.
Why aren't we doing the same with our
behaviors that affect our everyday?
Now I'm sure some
of y'all might be asking,
"OK, I thought we were talking
about workplace burnout.
Why aren't we talking more
about our workplaces and our employers?"
Which is where I'll offer
a little bit of a plot twist.
Yes, when it comes to burnout,
our workplaces and employers
do own a big part of the equation.
However, what I find to be
somewhat of an overlooked part
of the equation today
is what piece of the problem
we individually own ourselves, too.
If I inherently have a tendency
or a pattern to overwork
or not be able to set boundaries
no matter what workplace
or organization I change.
If I never take accountability
to drive my own internal change,
then no matter what external
change I make,
I will likely keep suffering
from the same patterns
over and over again.
Now, all that being said and all that
being something I strongly believe in,
I am also a realist and I know
that not all of us
will be ready to do our own
deep personal work yet.
So where else can we start on this topic?
What else can we do?
I'll offer three smaller steps.
First,
when you find yourself wanting to say
"we're like family" around work
or organizations,
try to get clearer in your communication
and use language
that has better boundaries.
As Brené Brown says,
"Clear is kind. Unclear is unkind."
So if you find yourself wanting
to say "We're like family,"
but you're really kind of
asking for a favor,
clarify that, say, "Hey, you know,
we actually need this
deliverable a week sooner.
What can we do to achieve that?"
Or if you're just trying to communicate
a value about your organization,
again, clarify the language
and use boundaries.
Say, "It's a priority for our teams
to feel trust and connection."
Or, as my friend Trey,
the CEO of Kronologic,
says to his team, he says,
"We're not like a family;
we're like a professional sports team."
It still infers that same
warmth and camaraderie,
but within the boundaries of a workplace.
Now, when it comes to this topic,
it's not to say that you can't have deep,
meaningful relationships from work,
but it is to point out that we need
to practice healthy boundaries
so that we can sustain healthy
workplaces and relationships.
The second tip I'll offer
is to actually do the work
to learn and model healthy
boundaries for one another.
If you are a people-pleaser who tends
to overscope and overcommit,
try buying some time
before you respond and commit.
Say, "Hey, I need to evaluate this
against my other priorities.
Can I get back to you
by the end of the day?"
Give yourself some time
for that behavioral change
instead of getting stuck
in the same repetitive pattern.
When you're communicating boundaries,
clarify what you need
and what the impact will be
if you don't get that need met.
Say, "If we need this product
a month sooner,
I'm going to need the help
of two other people.
Otherwise, the quality
is really going to be at risk,
and we might either lose
team members or customers."
Remember that when
you're communicating boundaries,
that's not a "me versus you" fight,
but it's what we need to do
to collectively come together
to resource ourselves,
to sustain our organizations,
workplaces and relationships.
Last tip I will offer
is to see if you can find one way
to empower mental health
for yourself or others this year.
I will recognize that just when it comes
to talking about mental, emotional health,
our behaviors and our past,
that can feel tender, personal.
But it can especially feel
a little scary or stigmatized
when we are talking
about working with experts
like psychologist or psychotherapist.
I'll close here by offering
a reframe in that thinking,
a reframe in that stigma.
When it comes to any other
important part of our lives,
we seek out experts.
When it comes to our physical health,
we seek out doctors.
Financial health,
we seek out financial advisors.
Why is it that when it comes
to our mental health,
we think we should take
care of it on our own?
We would never look at a friend
who's having a heart attack and be like,
"You should really
take care of that yourself,
otherwise you're kind of weak.
You should not need
to go to the hospital."
Why is it that we think we can grow
or develop our mental health
when most of us don't have the tools
or education to do so?
So today,
whether it is your propensity to burn out,
your struggle with setting boundaries
or something different,
I hope you can feel a little bit
more free and empowered
to start building more meaning
and sustainability into your life.
Thank you for your time.
(Applause)